totalement sont venus chercher il ya 20
ans nous avions fait un reportage sur le
50e anniversaire de la libération des
camps de la mort à auschwitz était un
lieu de recueillement sobre calme
terrifiant lorsque les fours ne
suffisait pas il y avait la plupart des
guides étaient des survivants des cas
c'est ça et claude b derrière ses vitres
voici des contenants de zyklon b
des pastilles de gaz très toxique qui tu
es en 15 minutes le temps passe 50 ans
60 ans 70 ans et on commence à entrer
dans l'histoire et quitter la mémoire
parce que les témoins disparaissent aux
dernières commémorations il encore
beaucoup de témoins je pense qu'on aura
beaucoup moins les grandes figures
vieillissent et je crois que c'est un
challenge aussi c'est à dire comment
maintenant on va présenter l'histoire de
l'extermination des juifs comme non pas
comme un souvenir terrible des juifs
mais comme une prévention
encore une fois chauds dean le père
patrick desbois consacre sa vie à
documenter les massacres de juifs commis
en ukraine
de 1941 à 1944 à clefs la shoah par
balles
là c'est le fusil
ça c'est le bordeaux si on était libre
et ça s'est vu
il estime qu'il ya là 1200 faussement a
enterré un million de victimes juives
lui aussi lutte pour que l'on n'oublie
pas que l'on préserve à auschwitz des
objets et les lieux qui témoigne de
cette entreprise systématique
d'élimination d'une race oui c'est
surtout en tout cas le plus grand
cimetière juif puisque au fond du camp
il ya toutes ces chants de fosse commune
avec les premières chambres à gaz le
bunker à une bonne cure deux qui étaient
des fermes en fait que été aménagée en
chambre à gaz
donc c'est sûr que c'est le plus grand
cimetière juif du monde est sûrement
peut-être même le plus grand cimetière
du monde mais les gens souvent peuvent
oublier qu'ils vont dans un cimetière
ils pensent qu'ils font dans un musée
aujourd'hui le tourisme est en
croissance perpétuelle plus d'un million
de visiteurs par année groupe après
groupe se succèdent dans ce qui est
devenu un vaste musée comme dans tous
lieux touristiques il y a des
distributrices à café des barres et des
files d'attentes interminables autre
fois ce lieu de mémoire et est
accessible gratuitement
maintenant les polonais doivent payer
l'équivalent de 10 $ pour y accéder les
touristes étrangers 15 dollars et s'il
n'a bougé peur j'ai peur d'un auschwitz
qui ne fait plus peur et on nous suis
grand lieu de tourisme ne fait pas peur
c'est là on achète les souvenirs 1 c'est
là on mange des hot dogs
j'aimerais autoriseront tr/min et elle
chute
si tu veux faire la visite tu arrives
ils ont trois jours avant tu étudies
dans un centre d'études
tu apprends ce que c'était et ensuite tu
entres sur les mieux au risque de ton
âme mais qui reste là en contact au
point que c'est possible avec la réalité
du lieu et j'espère que tu sors terrifié
par rassurer avant j'ai vu le musée un
nom que tu sortes terrifiée parce que
franchement si on ne sort pas d'eau
chaude 8
eri filles et hitler a gagné
ce que je pensais que les gens risquent
simplement comme le temps s'éloigne de
visiter ce lieu comme un lieu horrible
mais en oubliant tse des hommes des
femmes avec un nom un prénom une valise
des affaires qui arrivait là et hop leur
vie s'arrêtait pour lui sinon on est
impressionné par les barbelés on a
impressionné par arbeit macht frei mais
c'est pas ça qui tue les gens ce qu'ils
tuaient les gens c'est les gens qui
étaient là dedans c'est toutes ses
troupes de ss est aussi d'auxiliaires
qui veut assassiner les gens je serai
c'est un lieu de crime